bloody power Shane Cashman Douglas oh
Cashman
the crack journalist for for Beanie
Siegel over there too Gonzo journalist
yeah Gonzo
after after this [__] little gay
essay he's writing he's gonna be a dunso
journalist yeah hey hey Mercy remember
that time that Hunter S Thompson stayed
at the topic of his article's parents
house yes I drink probably did but even
on top of that it would still be
interesting
um so before just before we we see if
this article was is going to be a you
know
objective
this is just a reminder if this is the
guy who was writing the article his work
will end up being warhol-esque in a way
where thank you I'm serious
what would be warhol-esque thank you I
don't know how else to articulate it but
I think no you're really gifted and very
talented and I'm grateful this is what
this entire this is their entire economy
yeah this is why and if you check out
Marsh on Twitter I uh I finally finally
get to take advantage of the old 4 000
character tweet thing and uh you know
basically explain Tim's whole little
circle
they make a bunch of money and they
freeze every other Creator out as it's
been proven with as much as I hate
boring Jeremy Tim's whole thing with the
quartering just proves that he's the guy
from daily wire no that's Jeremy boring
oh okay boring Jeremy okay from the
quartering but Tim's treatment using
because they're both boring
Tim's treatment of both Fenty and the
quartering
um of freezing them out because they're
not part of the club and they don't want
to make enough sweet sweet money like so
there's these little clicks and it's
like it's a pyramid dude so Tim's
freezing out quartering a Britney venti
people like Brittany venti and the
quartering will freeze people like us
out because everyone wants to sort of
like be the top dog Tim's entire click
besides the money their only other
currency he's he's niceties they the
only thing you have to do to stay cool
in their little click is lie for them
and then just constantly saying fake
nice [__] man Tim that song is brilliant
dude this guy he's a regular War haul so
brilliant like that literally is all you
have to do is just show up for late and
be nice and never expose anybody and
they'll let you earn a little they'll
let you have some crumbs off the table
it's disgusting I'm so sick of Temple
yeah we're gonna do a thing you know
what I think would be really cool and I
know you're trying to end the show but
I've had this Vision a little bit of you
coming out to the farm and really seeing
what my day-to-day life is like so this
was already planned out for him coming
out to the farm but it's a big house not
a farm but going out to the farm this
was already planned out in advance
before the whole thing go out of the
farm yeah and it's totally different
than this Glam version yeah yeah that's
the Glam oh that's right at the farm
she's out there with buckets in her hand
milk and cows she keeps saying this like
foreign
[Applause]
I drive my dad's farm truck and I was
like I better dad's farm truck is one of
those like Dodge Ram double cab probably
like you know what I mean that's
probably two years old and has like it's
probably fully loaded it's probably not
a farm truck yeah
it's one of those trucks the
construction company owner buys for
himself but he's not going to be caught
dead hauling buckets of paint in it and
[__] you know it's just gonna put his
logo for his company on it so this whole
thing was this whole thing was set up
beforehand but anyway this is the stuff
that had come out today
um apparently
this was this is after Eliza's first
appearance on Tim cast the video is very
poor quality so uh let's see let's let's
see
if maybe we could pinpoint the
friendliness and pinpoint why Tim
doesn't like talking about ethos and
e-drama which he does all the time by
the way not only Tim why not and why not
only Tim doesn't like talking about oh
why nobody wants to talk about it
um
you know what I'm in the middle of a
story right now
Adam
oh I get it
I want my apology Adam I get it now this
makes a lot more sense honestly
I'll send someone out
oh boy wow they're really friendly here
can I cue the uh uh
no way huh
this is
this looks inappropriate this looks like
you know what dare I say Royce a
conflict of interest
uh Samurai cicada said Royce said he
would block people who were following
Tim Poole back then no I said that I
that wasn't me I never said that I said
I didn't care enough about Twitter to
bother logging in and unfollowing but
Royce kept I didn't block anybody I
haven't blocked anybody on Twitter no
and I never said I'd block I said at one
point because Tim's always having stupid
dog [__] takes and he's always grifting
I said something to the effect of I'm
going to start unfollowing everybody
I didn't say that and I didn't block it
I haven't blocked anybody who's that the
[__] Chad sumac that's Chad sumac
yeah he's safe only person that confuses
us Sam writes the kid is a dirty clubs
no man I was if you're blocked let me
know I'll unblock you but I haven't
blocked anybody on purpose anyway
wait why are you hiding now
yeah no it's a little little Groove
she's hiding because she's kind of
almost a better grifter than you guys
and she knows how to create some
deniability
Eliza
see the problem is you got to assign a
guy like me to a case like this because
even if I do end up [__] the chick I
will still throw her in front of a bus
I'll still write it totally honest
brutal article
look look you know I wonder why
yeah hey let me tell you something I'm
not gonna make any accusations because
some of these people are very litigious
but what I do know is in my experience
people that have body language like that
are about to or have had some sort of
sex yeah I don't know I don't not saying
that they did in any way I'm just saying
I know a lot that is a Telltale sign how
would anyone feel if it was your wife
and it was one of your buddies Do It
Like Glue acting like that right like
that's all you got to ask yourself
how would you feel you walk in a room
and your wife's sitting there like
rolling around couch you'd be like oh
what are we doing here
why are they two of them look exactly
the same in here
what is that your foot oh my God whoa
come on man I didn't know the video was
even this spicy oh no no there's a it
gets spicy spicy your foot
all of these people the difference
between us and them I like to think is
like we're pieces of [__] all the time
and you can see how we are on air off
air that's pretty much us that's
ironically the arbit is of truth right
we're pieces of [__] being [__]
turkeys mad at us for playing Tetris
music while building smell that was fun
and they were tweeting us today and they
go these guys or people are dying we can
[__] out all the time but it's like so
we're [__] and we're not pretending to
be smarter we're not trying to we're not
trying to save anybody and the intro by
the way we're joking around we're not
saving anywhere from civilization the
whole [__] joke is is that we're just
[__] telling stupid jokes about
stuff that we want to talk about these
people really think like you heard Tim
gold we have we have congressmen coming
on and was bobert by the way she was on
yesterday yeah she was on a Gates
forward and some other [__] right
yeah whatever still wore the same outfit
right so again
you guys are all these weird groupy
pieces of [__] behind the scene and then
when people when you ask why you you you
can't you could be this if you want you
could be just a [__] dumb idiot but
you know what you're not gonna have
merch and I aren't gonna [__] go out
there go you know what we're sending a
crack team of journalists to [__] to
take a I'm not gonna do that we don't
care I don't have to I just look at you
and go you're a [__] lion yeah that
story has holes so like [__] this man of
course the story is not going to be true
it's all [__] and again I want to be
clear I don't wouldn't have even cared
this much if people weren't getting
kicked off of Twitter for it
all right
and that's the thing man just be an open
book like us
you know what I mean make things a
non-issue I mean it's you know [__] I've
had people coming at me for three years
and everything they have is just [__]
that's come straight from the horse's
[__] mouth I've you know there's
never been there's never been a [__]
Revelation about any of us you know what
I mean just be who you are embrace it
and in that way if something does come
out people didn't know you go well yeah
but that fits my character what do you
want but honestly not even that even if
Ian even if Ian would have said like
look honestly like I don't really I
don't really want to pass any judgment
here because I you know we're friends we
hang out so I don't think I'm gonna be
objective here and that's it that people
have been like okay hey you know what
fair game nobody would be mad but the
fact that you're trying to pretend like
you could hang out do mushrooms smoke
[__] weed play guitar get hammered
put your foot on people's dicks and then
be like no hey
this this story is going to be on the up
and up Tim I get it bud I wouldn't want
to [__] have to talk about this
either if I were you I get it and now
he's trying to do the sarcas the irony
bro stuff on Twitter you've seen Tim
doing the irony bro stuff on Twitter
doing the whole um
um doing the whole
it's actually good it's fine oh I'm not
training again I better Eliza was always
something controversial again yeah yeah
yeah I would say this though Royce the
only thing I'll correct you on is you're
like I wouldn't want to talk about it
either no you're wrong because the way
we are we would be wired to talk no no
what I meant was his if I was Tim pool
of but yeah but I'm saying the way we
are yes like this whole thing blew up
and some grifter was on our show that we
had as guest and in one of like one of
us banging him right we would just lean
right into it right away and be like all
right look I was [__] this chick
I don't know what the [__] was going on
whatever but like if this [__] surfaced
we would just pull whoever was [__]
her on the air and be like so what's up
man you were banging her like come on
come clean you piece of [__] come on
tell us what's going on that's all
uh um
all right let's see uh oh this okay so
this this is the next one uh in this
series
um that's not that's not my priority
okay
look we got some dancers in the back
Geo Ian was straight smashing there and
uh we think we think
good for you um all right we got the
strippers in the back
wow that's dude she was a victim
and honestly a triggering statement like
that could really send her that you know
could send her into a tailspin it's not
funny man
you sound kind of like an [__]
never watched
never watch a double date on here
so it is a double date
so they were no one corrected them so my
assumption is that she had some sort of
physical maybe not dating but they could
have [__]
and all makes all of this entire story
no wonder Tim didn't stand up for not
censoring people like you normally it
was no wonder he pushed this aside can I
ask yeah could Eliza blue potentially be
the kalila Kune of the alt grift right
could she just be a wrecking ball that
comes in and undoes this whole [__]
thing by just being a Shameless [__]
piece of [__]
it's always [__] isn't it yeah
how long is the story of Helen of Troy
been around
thousands at least 20 30 years at least
at least 1964. at least
but like
they wrote a cautionary Greek tragedy
how long ago
very long and it's like
how many people read it it's not even
it's a Lex Friedman level story that
everyone knows
and and and and
[__] still just getting undone
by some [__] every time
unlike unlike kalilah Eliza actually
cast a wider net so it might be even
worse with Eliza that you know
[Music]
so this is the thing that I that again
and we talked about this too
you can't just hang out
without a camera on
you can't just have just just chill have
some beers hang out like play the guitar
like normal people do you know the
answer to that question how many people
have we hung around I know in every city
in this country anytime we meet up with
streamers there's a very short list of
streamers
who know how to just hang out right like
dick Masterson's one of them ricada is
one of them Carl from where these
podcasts is one of them there are very
few people who are uh Chrissy and Frank
I'll give them correct because once the
show is over they hung out but they just
hung out there was no like guys let's go
on Instagram
like eating slop with these [__]
pieces
eating horse slop with these [__]
horse no but it's like there was just
all right show's over that was a great
show we have fun hey let's go get some
beers let's go get a bite to eat and
there's none of that like guys I'm gonna
go live we'll go a lot it's like all
right man like you're making millions of
dollars just play your guitar and eat
your mushrooms to just hang out
oh by the way a cicada I unblocked you
check guys check to see if you're people
are blocked that you don't know
Twitter's been really weird for you too
right like it's been [__] all day on
yeah oh yeah they once they rolled out
that 4 000 limit thing it broke Twitter
yes yeah man and my DMs were a mess
uh Scarface says Eliza doesn't strike me
as the type who uh do white boys but
we'll give them head to move up no
she'll do what shows you white boys 100
I'm not saying she doesn't do black guys
but she does white boys too this is this
is trust me
when you when you're when you're one of
these grifting background dancing hoes
the color doesn't matter
it's whiter Man true
[Music]
guts everyone suck at music that's just
it with him
hey remember when I was saying the guy
that just placed a bunch of chords and
doesn't play a song at a party you just
want to break the guitar but it's like
you're Jeff Jarrett
how about that slap nuts
let's say how synthesized it goes Eliza
blue everyone who would do something for
her
by the way nobody Adam and this dork
Adam and her look like they're having
fun but Eliza is a good thing you could
tell lies not having actual fun she's
very good at just blending in but in her
head she's like
yeah she would rather be in Chicago at
some [__] club with some rapper she
rather she rather have [__] Lupe
Fiasco in her yes
and all the cats in the street [__]
with any kick pushes around the [__]
door
[Music]
can this end like all the videos of
people playing music I saw in Ukraine
oh yeah and let it out
all right there we go yo what's another
song
[__] nothing we're done with this you
should you should [__] disconnect the
gas Main and then play Taps
[Laughter]
that was very funny piece of [__] so
that there's your temple update I ain't
doing an hour again today I [__]
hippies
skateboarding [__]